hey guys it's max in this video we're
gonna be comparing the brand-new 2020
MacBook Air against the previous 2019
version and we're not only gonna see how
much better is the new quad core i5 CPU
compared to the previous dual core i5
we're also going to compare the graphics
and this has the best g7 graphics in it
but we're also gonna look at things such
as the speakers the webcam quality and
we're even the take off the bottom
covers and see did Apple make any
changes to the cooling so a lot of
interesting things of course we're gonna
take a look at this new keyboard as well
and let's just get started with the
exteriors now if we close these up you
guys will see that this is basically
identical the size the shape nothing
changed at all the new 2020 version did
get just a little bit heavier 2.8 pounds
compared to 2.75 but other than that we
have no changes and then opening these
guys up again you guys will see the 13.3
inch displays they are identical so
there's still retina quality nice and
sharp but they still don't get the same
brightness that the MacBook Pros do and
as far as the color accuracy they still
lack dcpip three color gamut coverage
now one of the biggest things that
people are excited about with the new
2020 MacBook Air are the new keyboards
this is the second MacBook to offer
Apple's new magic keyboard as they call
it now I don't know if it's magic but it
certainly is good if you guys have tried
one of the sixteen inch MacBook Pros you
guys will know that basically this takes
all the benefits of Apple's previous
chiclet keys which are the better travel
distance and the great reliability but
it also combines it with the best parts
of the butterfly keyboard so we have
larger key caps that are very stable and
some better feedback so you know it's
not exactly a mechanical keyboard but it
is closer to that so it really feels
fantastic and you have no issues with
the reliability now I have to say that
I'm not somebody that hated on the
butterfly keys I liked how tactile they
feel but people had issues with the
reliability now the 2019 model this has
the latest version of Apple's butterfly
keys and I have not
any issues with the reliability so if
you guys want to pick up one of these
refurbished MacBook Airs there are some
really really amazing deals on
amazon.com so I'll leave a link down in
the video description now Apple didn't
mention if they upgraded the camera or
the microphones so here is a sample
using the 720p webcam from the 2019
MacBook Air and this is the webcam and
microphone quality with the 2020 MacBook
Air you guys let me know if you notice
any differences down in the comment
section below now on Apple's website
they mentioned that this MacBook Air is
25% louder and has twice the base as a
previous MacBook Air and that would get
you thinking not they're probably
comparing it to the previous release but
when you look at the fine print they're
actually comparing it to the previous
2017 and older models but I am still
curious so let's take a listen to the
speakers and you guys put on some good
headphones so let me know if you guys
hear any differences
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
very interesting I want to hear your
opinions did you guys tell any
difference now to me personally the
older MacBook Air actually sounds
slightly louder and I went back and
forth multiple times but the new one
it's almost like they brought the volume
down just a little bit I made sure that
they're both maxed out
but the mids and the base just have a
little bit more of a punch and the base
is a little bit deeper it's not a huge
difference but it is definitely
noticeable I'm excited to open these up
and see maybe they did switch out the
speakers so now let's go ahead and jump
into performance as I'm running
Geekbench five here I'll say that this
laptop 2020 MacBook Air is the first
MacBook or Mac in general that features
Intel's tenth generation processors
which are more efficient and this I five
is now a quad-core processor now the new
MacBook Air does feature an i3 option if
you get the base model and that saves
you a hundred dollars then it's a dual
core and that dual core will actually
slightly outperform this dual core even
though it's an i3 both these laptops do
have eight gigs of ram except the new
one uses low power ddr4 at a higher
frequency as well we're almost at the
end of the test this is where it's doing
a bunch of multi-core stuff and I can
hear the fan in the 2020 not the 2019
and this one is completely silent
let's compare both these right now so as
far as single core performance we have
866 compared to 1166 with the new one
now that is a very good single core
score and my Mac Pro isn't that much
better than this one and most Mac's are
very similar now as far as multi-core
score you guys can see we have almost
twice the score with this new machine so
once you're going to be putting it
through some tasks that want some extra
power you are definitely going to have
that now let's talk about graphics 2019
version uses Intel's
6:17 whereas the new MacBook Air not
only does it use the iris plus graphics
the i5 version uses the g7 alright and
we have our scores and Wow ok so once
again the 2020 MacBook Air did better
than before by close
to a thousand points higher and this
MacBook Air actually scored also about a
thousand points higher than our previous
tests this thing is doing great and as
far as going back to the CPU here the
CPU actually scored higher than the
previous tests as well so for the
graphics when we're comparing those the
new MacBook Air is about two and a
quarter times more powerful as far as
graphics and that's compared to this
score compared to the previous graphics
score it's almost three times faster
that is impressive now there is also an
i7 option that is also quad-core has the
same graphics as the i5 but it just has
a little bit higher boost clocks and
slightly higher base clocks for 150
bucks more and I would not recommend
that processor now the next thing that
I'm curious about is thermal performance
I have cinnamon char xx here which is
gonna push all the course to their
limits let's hit run it's gonna give us
a lot of information so first off the
old MacBook Air goes up to 3.6 gigahertz
compared to 3.5 for this one and wow
it's going up to 26 watts compared to
1415 is drawing a lot of power but now
it is starting to slow down because of
thermals and this manoomin book here is
almost at 90 degrees compared to 86 so
not too far off and as far as clock
speeds it's running a two point one
compared to pretty much three gigahertz
now both of these are running at a
hundred degrees Celsius now and the
wattage came down and the frequencies
came down and we see the new MacBook Air
is running at about 1.75 gigahertz
compared to 2.6 gigahertz so we have two
cords that are running faster compared
to four cords running slower because of
thermals and here we have it we have 645
points for the 2019 MacBook Air and a
thousand and 19 points for the 2020 now
it's looking more like about 65% but
that is still a huge improvement and to
be completely honest with you guys
almost nobody is going to be just max
out the CPU 100% of time for you know a
very long period of time it took four
for these tests to get done even with
other MacBooks like for video editing
it's usually spiking up and down thirty
percent fifty percent then it goes lower
it's really using the graphics more so
and that is a pretty respectable
difference under load with both these
guys being really hot now let's go ahead
and get out the iFixit toolkits pop off
the bottom covers and see what kind of
differences apple gave us now
unfortunately just like I expected
because of the thermals that we saw the
heatsink is still not connected to the
fan which is crazy it is a little bit
different of a design there's a little
kind of chambers now which could help
the cooling a little bit but we still
see these super high temperatures and I
wish that Apple actually change this
because we now have a quad-core
processor I have no idea why they didn't
but it does heat up quite a bit and if
we actually did have it connected
properly like on a 13-inch MacBook Pro
we apply a twenty to thirty percent
better performance so with all those
tests and comparisons completed which
one would I buy well I think that's a
funny question that's obvious I would
get the new 2020 if we compare the base
prices alone the 2020 is gonna cost a
hundred bucks less and give you double
the storage with better CPU and GPU
performance or if we match up the prices
this will get much better graphics
performance double the cores with sixty
five to eighty percent better
performance maybe even a hundred percent
depending on what you're doing if it
doesn't heat up as much and we're
getting the extra SSD space now of
course it gets a bit more complicated
because the 2019 is discounted right now
300 bucks off meaning spec for a spec
they match up and in that case it's
still very obvious to get the new one or
if you're comparing a refurbished one
compared to a new one that's where it
gets a little more difficult but
personally I would pay at least an extra
200 bucks to get this brand new one even
if it was just for the keyboard alone
using it's a much better experience
you'd have to worry about reliability
but then stacking up all the performance
differences and man this new 2020
MacBook Air is a very very good machine
nothing's coming
extremely popular so let me know your
thoughts down in the comment section
below once again I have links to both
this one and this one right here with
the refurbished option down in the video
description so you guys use those links
that help support the channel and it is
really nice in this tough time so I hope
you guys are doing well click that
subscribe button above if you guys want
to see our comparison to the MacBook Pro
the base 13-inch has a quad core that's
going to be a very interesting video
that's been Mac's and I'll see you in
the next one
[Music]